so when he's black occasionally a bit
vulnerable some uh very controversial
opening choices as we've seen so far in
the tournament and the few times we have
seen Magnus uncomfortable is when
players attack
save origin we'll do that here we go
this is game one in the final yep and uh
it's the ready opening white bringing
his night out on the first move
um now black is just developing his
Bishop very sensible black is occupied
the center with pawns but uh White is
super flexible white usually castles the
king here or pushes a pawn forward in
the center of the board
and uh yeah I mean there's plenty of
ways this game could go Magnus allows
black to fully occupy the center Arjun
says no just bringing Knights out and
it's crunch time now how is Magnus gonna
continue with his pieces is he going to
stab his Queen's pawn two squares
forward I suppose we've seen him do
before maybe just one step one step
forward or maybe he's actually gonna
pick up a Seaborn and move that one two
squares
Anything Can Happen yeah and Magnus he's
played these types of positions before
and he loves the flexibility he loves uh
just being able to choose from a bunch
of different plans but black is Rock
Solid Audrey clearly knows what he's
going to be doing
and uh yeah it's hard to surprise the
really well for bad young Indian player
what do you predict David do you think
I don't know it'll be a pawn Bush I just
don't know which one
symmetrical position
and uh he did something very similar
against uh Vincent kaimer no it was
slightly different than his the dark
Square Bishop was
I think against the odenban forest a few
times on the tour at least twice on the
tour that I remember and uh yeah Magnus
just picking his poison so had it a few
times
against our Jordan Farm Fresh yeah
Magnuson I remember one game was a very
very uh interesting draw and I think
Magnus might have won the other one
um okay he pushes the pawn just one
square usually that pawn pushes two
squares forward but
um this is still well known stuff Arjun
clearly has done his preparation black
pushing upon I really love what black is
doing actually with his last Pawn push
just gaining space on the queen side and
meanwhile Magnus developing pieces it
feels to me like Magnus wants to avoid
the opening battle that's a kind of Mark
of respect to his opponent he doesn't
want to get involved in any kind of
pre-game opening preparation discussions
he just wants to play chess essentially
yeah to get his pieces onto good squares
and check in the database uh not too
many games and there have been two games
though by a former world champion
Vladimir kramnik yeah David how did you
know that David uh kramnik was famous
not for this last bishop move by white
by the previous porn move nobody ever
played it everyone thought oh it looks
really unambitious but kramnik played it
and kramnik is a trendsetter in the
opening
also studied this type of thing from
white and black I've played
too many games more than I can remember
in this type of opening not this exact
position but this uh
start of the opening and this last queen
move looks a bit mysterious but White's
Queen and dusker Bishop have lined up
yep they have lined up and no one has
actually dared to do this before so we
are in New Territory and that always is
very exciting because yep the queen and
Bishop have lined up but it's very
interesting to see what's going to
happen next is this a novelty then yeah
oh yeah yeah
and we can call it novelty so because do
we only call them Novelties later on
when we realized it was a great move or
can we call them Novelties right now we
can call them Novelties right away I
mean it can be a terrible move in the
opening but that doesn't matter because
if no one has paid it before you get
first dibs ah a good novelty or bad
novelty they're still Novelties yeah and
uh yeah chess players they really Pride
themselves on finding these new ideas
that nobody in history has ever thought
of before
had a few in my time and I still look
back at them with pride so the novelty
is the one Arjun just made or was it
Magnus okay magnus's little Queen moved
to the side
I don't think it was a planned novelty
it's more like a spontaneous uh decision
just maybe just like the speed with
which arjun's been playing and I just
wanted to throw him off balance White
Queen move now looks a bit odd this
white knight developing uh to the square
in the center it blocks the White Queen
hmm so what could have been magnus's
plan with uh than that novelty then well
I think I think it's uh primarily to
potentially exchange of dark Square
Bishops but I say potentially because it
has to be done at the right time because
there's no point in doing it now and uh
the reason why I'm like don't do it
right now is just because uh take a look
at Black's dark Square Bishop it's
blocked up it's got pieces in the way
yeah so it looks like the queen and
Bishop are lining up so that you could
initiate this trade but
um SE Ivanka says it doesn't look too
impressive instead pushing this Pawn
forward is another secondary idea behind
the queen stepping to the square ideally
the queen doesn't want to get in the way
of her Rooks looks a bit clumsy but uh
she does support this Pawn potion yeah
this this Pawn structure now it's
reminiscent of a Queen's Gambit uh White
having two Pawns in the center black
just solidifying it's like a slav type
of defense and usually white is the one
who holds the key white can decide when
to capture or when to push forward black
doesn't really want to capture himself
in the current position for example now
because the White Queen will spring
forward and white has extra space due to
the spawn in the center
uh so very tense right now white has the
bishop Power white has slightly more
space as we mentioned but uh black is
Rock Solid and I wouldn't be surprised
to see Eric I see maybe push this Pawn
forward gain a bit of space on this
flank black is slightly cramped uh maybe
the Black Knight can jump into the
center at some point uh often black just
pushes this Pawn to create kind of a
triangle formation uh in the center
Alexis options looks good I've also seen
maybe not in this exact position but I
also
um seen black move the Knight over to
the B6 Square just to ask white what are
you gonna do are you gonna capture pawns
are you going to push forward just to
determine the pawn structure yeah so
that one might appear later as well and
okay he uses the queen on this Square
um also very active and white needs to
somehow get these Rooks into the game
to be honest I slightly prefer White's
position just because long term Bishop
pair if it does ever open up there we go
one of the white Rooks does centralize
yeah if it ever opens up Magnus with
this great air quality that we see in
front of us uh he will be the favorite
but uh yeah still early days
yeah uh early days but a lot of
excitement I'm super enthusiastic about
this particular match-up youth against
old although it's not really old it's
like Magnus Carls and the champ but
anyway we love it here when everyone at
home joins in the farm and joins in the
excitement so please share with us your
thoughts send us your pictures your
photos your questions and you can do all
this by using by tweeting us using the
hashtag chess Champs we'll try and
feature them on the show yeah it's gonna
be so much fun we love your questions
especially yeah I love it when when the
viewers get very creative and send us
their funny pictures absolutely I I
still giggle when I remember that
competition about uh Simon yeah
I said time now again what's wrong today
me and Simon ever have babies
oh that's the second time today I said
Simon Howell I have no idea why
Simon Cowell Media mode maybe I was
watching maybe I was drinking dreaming
about what is it American Idol X Factor
is Simon Cowell yep
yeah but do do tweet your questions and
comments you guys a queen move by Arjun
here a queen move and it's actually the
same idea that Ivanka mentioned just in
a different different uh way essentially
black is putting pressure on white sea
Pawn the black queen is looking at the
C4 Square the black Central Pawn looking
at that square as well so he's just same
to Magnus it's your choice you make the
decision I want you to clarify the
center it's going to be relatively
blocked up I guess Magnus doesn't really
want to trade Pawns in the middle of the
board and if he doesn't then he has a
problem to deal with that is a pawn
attacked after all so yeah very logical
move
um I like what arjun's doing in general
and I and I mean definitely this is two
generations obviously Arjun a teenager
Magnus Carlsen 31 years old
how long
do you think David Magnus Carlsen will
be
the number one player in the world how
many years do you give him ish you give
him like two years 10 years 20 years
five you know uh not 20 not 20. okay I
think that will be difficult to keep up
the youngsters coming through now are
just too strong I don't think they'll
let him kind of rest in peace uh not
rest in peace peacefully at the top of
your chest
peacefully at the top of the standings I
meant but uh yeah the youngsters they're
coming up to kill the king and uh
they'll want to take that spot uh as
number one I do feel Magnus to have many
years left in him at the top level but I
mean the fact that he stepped aside from
the World Championship uh there are
other small factors as well
remember Gary Kasparov retired at I
think 43 kramnik retired at 41. so
there are indicators that it's not easy
to go on at your Peak Beyond uh the age
of 40. there are exceptions of course
but yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was just
gonna say just recently Federer yeah
that's his retirement I think he lost
his game yesterday he did lose it but it
was you know I I saw it when I came home
and I just cried and cried yeah that
interview afterwards oh my God I'm a
doll yeah but crying yeah oh yeah now
that was sobbing
that was too soft man
sorry
but it's nice to see you know it shows
how much it means to them yeah I'm sure
the day Magnus retires he'll shed a tear
or two as well I think you two will be
the federal and all you'll be on the
side there they were just so big yeah I
think I think so because I actually I
don't recall crying but I remember
feeling tremendously sad when Gary
announced his retirement I can imagine
and uh I don't know why but he's kind of
captivating my imagination so then when
he announces that he's playing again
just in some kind of uh Fisher random
tournament I'm like oh he's gonna win
you know he's got that much of an aura
around him
yeah unfortunately it didn't quite go so
well but yeah yeah it's just difficult I
guess life gets in the way you just
don't have as much time when you're
slightly older to study as much as maybe
some of these young players do
I mean you still have the understanding
plenty of these slightly older players
they have uh they still have the energy
everything else but it's
it's difficult and uh it does seem to be
a Young Person's game now in this
generation cup meanwhile Magnus just
shuffling his Queen up one square
I mean it's so tense right now it's
really hard to call again I still prefer
white because he has the potential long
term of the bishop pair but Eric I sees
dancing around with his Knights
I like this last move I like this last
move as well you know it's asking
questions what are you going to do with
a pawn that's under Fire and Magnus can
either choose to defend it with a rogue
or potentially a pawn or determine the
pawn structure it's really cagey at the
minute both sides kind of prodding each
other trying to establish a plan also
that Knight doesn't need to stay on
sorry the night they just moved to the
D6 Square it doesn't have to stay on
that square it can actually maneuver
itself to the F5 square and to start
looking at the bishop and that's
probably going to be unpleasant as well
yeah for example you mentioned that this
Pawn structure
I mean there's a bit of pressure here if
white just defends if we're just
protects things this is very awkward
actually uh you'd never want to allow
the capture of your Bishop not just
because uh you want to keep your Bishop
pair but because this would wreck the
white Pawn structure if the Black Knight
captures you can't step back now because
the Knight would take the spawn uh you
could step forward but the bishop is not
entirely safe here either at the right
moment I'm not sure when the Black
Knight might come around and attack your
piece
and uh yeah I mean black Is Still Rock
Solid so Magnus I'm expecting him to
probably go for a move like this one
just to bring his Rook across to defend
this Pawn
butts in the current position maybe you
could make an argument for opening up
one file you could certainly make an
argument for stepping forward I know you
would uh you like these types of Pawn
structures if white can keep control
your anchor yeah that's correct it's a
big if because uh stepping forward again
allows the Black Knight to come and
attack your Bishop
but uh at least you gain a bit of space
here yeah it's very difficult it's
decision time for Magnus the other
option remember was to take but uh okay
he has stepped forward this would have
opened up a file maybe for the black
Rockstar occupy so instead he does gain
space this is
a maximalist approach I guess but the
problem is the center will be blocked
now look at these pawns and these pawns
they'll be locked up and that tends to
favor Knights rather than Bishops
yeah so I'm sure we'll see Arjun jump to
the square put some pressure on this
piece and
back to maneuvering it feels like uh
they're definitely just the Calm before
the storm in this final it's not what I
expected I thought we'd be seeing very
very aggressive just from the off but I
think that will be ahead
might not necessarily be in this game
Magnus meanwhile laughing to himself
we've seen this before yeah
usually a bad sign
yeah
he doesn't always uh look fully focused
oh occasionally some mistakes after he
starts laughing but we were critical I
remember during the FTX cop you know
because he just kept laughing and we
were like oh he's not focused but then
he ended up winning the tournament so
I'm gonna like reel in my words and just
say you do you Magnus but if you blunder
I'm blaming the laughter
we're so fickle here we'll change our
mind depending on the results we can be
and see people happy though
yeah definitely and talking about um
talking about happiness Adair G asks us
a question he asks um David myself I'm
going to also throw the question to you
Kaya were you good at maths when you
were in primary and High School
Kaya Fest what's my favorite subjects
but it doesn't mean I was very good at
it okay yeah I liked that it was uh I
like that because I would be very
suspicious of my teachers when they gave
me grades so you know in the other
subjects you know it was a little bit up
to the teacher what they thought about
you know the essay I wrote but in math I
knew it was the right or the wrong
answer yeah so that's why I liked it
yeah the reason I laughed earlier is
because I hated it a dancer yeah I think
I had one nice maths teacher ever
um but the rest
I don't know they would always be a bit
strict with me after I come back from a
chest one and often I would disappear
for a week or two at a time to play a
tournament I come back and they're like
you missed all your exams you missed the
classes you need to catch up you need to
do the next 50 pages and
I mean I was okay at it and I was never
amazing though so I never saw the
correlation between chess and mats
just felt like a chore to me I never
really understood why I would need
certain equations
yeah I think that's right though yeah
well well I wasn't I was good in primary
school because it was mainly about
memorization everyone can do that so I
was good at that part when it came to
the high school part no I was terrible
but having said that I did do some work
in my house that involved us sitting
down and using the pie formula
uh finally it came in handy well I
didn't remember I had to Google it and
it didn't even occur to me until we sat
there and like oh my goodness me like 20
minutes later we can use pie to work
myself so yeah there are some uses yeah
decimal points of power of pie do you
know I guess three two oh you can three
no no just three point one four that's
it and then 0.142 something something oh
interesting yeah impressive but uh
meanwhile the game's still locked up we
mentioned that Magnus closed the pawn
structure and uh okay the Black Knight
didn't go to the square we expected but
Arjun has solidified the Black Knight on
this queen Side by pushing a pawn
further down the board so gaining some
space I'm really not sure what Black's
doing with his Queen with his Knight but
they look nice and pretty for now
um it's just whether Magnus can create
any play Maybe on the other side there
we go tempting fate just on the other
side of the board this is actually very
logical in strategy terms uh the black
queen is far far away from her King she
can't really ever jump over to the
defense so why not attack on this right
half of the board
yeah thank you
I approved I
like as much space as you possibly can
but remember I love that phrase David
I'm gonna use it with great space comes
great responsibility because you know
there are certain squares that white has
given up beautifully the E4 Square so as
long as Magnus controls that and has the
ability to protect his King
I'm a big fan of what Magnus is doing
yeah this is a big hole in magnus's
position but for now it's guarded by the
bishop if the Black Knight could jump in
safely it would be a bit scary and yeah
like you say Ivanka at the moment okay
Magnus with his Pawn push he's clearly
going for the black king
he's going to throw lots of Pawns
forward but
the downside this white king is a bit
Airy it definitely feels to me like
Arjun needs to be doing something with
this queen with this Knight he can't
just leave them there forever on the
wrong flank because they're not going
anywhere and uh does that mean at some
point he prepares pushing this ball and
I don't think you can do it yet you want
to break down White's Pawn chain
especially the head of the pawn chain
clamping down on the black position uh
you want to kind of play this move but
the pawn next to it might fall so uh
could you prepare this move perhaps
could you start re-routing this Knight
back somewhere I'm not really sure
exactly where it's going I just don't
see how to get the queen in the game and
okay Arjun first pushes forward
expecting Magnus to lock up this side of
the board you never really want to take
this pawn and give the black queen a
reason to be excited
uh so yeah I'm expecting Magnus to just
to step forward one square maybe two
squares not sure which one is
which one appeals to you Ivanka
um I think
one square
two squares might allow the black queen
to sneak in yeah
offering a queen exchange I don't think
white wants to exchange Queens the more
pieces that disappear the more
responsibility of the space might become
a burden
okay he does push forward one square
um logical and the move that I was
considering here for black was actually
to step the queen one square forward and
with the same idea of actually just uh
trading off Queens I feel that White's
potential attack on the right side is
going to be a bit dangerous so trade of
Queens follow follow my motto but
instead Ira geissi just centralized his
Rook yeah I guess maybe there was a
small threat of white pushing this Pawn
forward if the blackrocker wasn't here
then the Black Knight would not be able
to use the square now it is possible for
example if the Knight is attacked the
Black Knight can Retreat safely
otherwise the Black Knight would have
been lacking any good squares so it
makes some sense what he's done but I
prefer your move as well you anchor if
it was possible
um clock times Magnus is actually two
minutes down on the clock Eric I see
with a lead there and uh this Pawn
structure looks nice for white visually
but actually you've lost control over
lots of light squares so I'm not sure
Magnus will want to commit yet to
pushing all his pawns to dark squares
will we see this Pawn push forward maybe
even this Pawn push forward or the white
Rooks start to improve this one is
probably the worst piece in the board so
you could make an argument for stepping
this white Rook forward somewhere I'm
not sure where and they're swinging the
other one across or okay it's the West
piece so he improves it to a different
Square he just brings it across the move
that I was attracted to
um it can still be done is actually
sliding the bishop one square forward
the light squared and then the king
stepping up and Swinging The Rooks over
in honor of our good friend Simon oh
Simon would love this your anchor we're
missing him here in the studio today but
he would be proud to slide The Rook
across and then push Harry the H Pawn on
the board and go for the black king
it's uh yeah Magnus didn't go for that
one and instead in the current position
we see the Black Knight drop back again
arjun's doing everything right uh he's
cramped lacking space for black so he's
trying to trade off pieces
yeah only one uh piece so far has left
the board
one set of knights Knights yeah one
night for white one
for tense nature of the position
the more we continue with this and okay
he's touched the other Bishop back this
is a clear indicator that Magnus wants
to step the white E Pawn for two squares
and just blow open the position
he just wants to push all the pawns
forward and it makes sense he has the
bishop
right a bishop pair
we are missing Simon in the studio but
he's enjoying himself
at the good night and as the watch party
started uh Simon do you have some Magnus
fan there with you
certainly do
so we've got lots of people here we can
see just like watching the chess we got
you on the screen which is obviously a
little bit a little bit strange and
people have certainly come down here
just to watch the chess and let's see if
we can ask someone about who they
think's gonna win right so we're in the
lovely good night we've got two lovely
people playing chess here
um hi to both of you and uh I know you
came down to watch the chess so uh first
of all who do you think's gonna win
Magnus of course of course are you
Norwegian by any chance no you're not
Norwegian oh where are you from from the
US from the US okay and you're and
you're supporting Magnus okay that's
awesome yeah and who do you think's
gonna win uh also Magnus yep okay so
you're both big Magnus fans right so
yeah
for sure and who's winning who's winning
this game
say him you say him okay okay so maybe
more beer if you have more beer you've
got to level the playing field a little
bit there okay well thank you very much
that's awesome so the watch party has
started we got the room here
um still lots of action going on so if
you're around come down enjoy the fun
have some beer watch the match and uh
yeah I'm enjoying myself here as well as
you can probably tell yeah ah very
enjoyable thank you Simon even people
from the US down at the good night to
follow there's uh Thursday and the final
best out of four rapid games either a
winner or they can of course also tie
this first match the second match will
be played tomorrow again for Rapid games
to decide the second match as well and
if they are tied after these two matches
then let's tie breaks
the bar is over to Magnus aside in this
first game does this look like a game
that will end up with a winner or is it
too early to say because so many pieces
on the board yeah it's too early we're
very far from a draw which is good news
lots of fight ahead one aspect we
haven't mentioned so far is the clock
and I think this might be a continual uh
theme throughout today and tomorrow in
the final Arjun he's super quick super
confident he's got a four and a half
minute time Advantage wow there we go
the bar slides down yeah I mean that was
I was very surprised actually I'm still
surprised at the bar's movement are now
but uh I mean a really light White's
position and I I didn't okay yes it's
very pleasant I admit that but is it
really as high as the bar was thinking
and now it says that
black
slightly better I don't really
understand why I mean is it because he
has a breakthrough right now is it
because he's going to kick the night
away I am confused as well I've got to
admit um the fact that the bar moved so
much means that there's something good
here for black but I'm struggling to see
it so there is a threat on the board
maybe we can try to get to the bottom of
this mystery
um there is a threat of Bishop takes
Rook this is very natural by white
um to me this was maybe one of the first
things I would have looked at as well in
every position we want to look for
forcing moves checks captures and
threats this is a big threat The Rook
can't move uh The Rook here is tied down
defending it's night therefore either
you have to block this attack somehow
there's only two or three ways to do
that or you have to kind of
counter-attack somehow I don't see any
counter attacks if you move your night
out and take the White Knight
maybe first of all white could just
recapture back on the Square with a pawn
uh say for example this way but maybe
white can get away with taking the black
Rook and it gets a bit complicated
around here the Knight could move back
the white Bishop is attacked it would
Retreat and now this Pawn in the center
would fall but okay Arjun pushes this
pawn another move potentially on the
radar was this Pawn push looking at that
I thought I was asking too much yeah I
mean this is uh very difficult without
the evaluation bar I don't think anyone
would even consider this move the whole
idea would be that if white takes with
this Pawn suddenly the Knight is loose
in the middle of the board there would
have been an exchange here and White's
Pawn structure is ruined doubled pawns
doubled pawns uh just everything weak
and the other idea I guess was after
Bishop takes there would have been a
pawn push hitting two pieces and still
super complicated we can't blame Arjun
for playing the safe move but the
evaluation bar goes up again for white
so maybe a small missed opportunity for
him watching this pawn and white
Retreats this is instructive for Magnus
no exchanges because after the retreat
Black's piece is far more passive than
White's piece I think that's a good good
thing to remember for everyone at home
don't go for exchanges unless they're
forced or if they improve your position
if your piece is worse than your
opponent's piece and here it's clear the
white tonight is better than blacks okay
Magnus pushes forward one square I was
expecting him to maybe try and push
forward two squares open it up but he's
happy to step forward maybe one idea is
to retreat the bishop with a pin on this
diagonal
or maybe even to line it up with the
White Queen on this diagonal
okay meanwhile Eric I see pushing his
Queen forward and Magnus doesn't indeed
Retreat his Bishop
furry tense who do you prefer here okay
your Banker Magnus suspicion I mean it
looks overwhelming actually because I'm
looking at the Black Knight on B5 and
it's completely misplaced
and his position is so grounded it feels
like Magnus is in Suffocation mode he's
that python wrapping around the victim
squeezing him from space
um I mean also I love this little bishop
move that he's made because it allows
the queen to swing all the way over to
the right side if needed and here it
comes grab operation grab as much as as
many squares as possible is is on the
board yeah I mean what are you going to
do you have to step up with that pawn
you can't take that ball you have to try
and block things as black but then the
Black Knights normally Knights love
blocked positions right but Black
Knights are just terrible right now
they're on poor circuits they can't
really go anywhere okay he tries to
improve this Knight but it did just come
from the square three moves ago
um yeah it feels like Eric is he's just
playing a bit too passive maybe it's
just the nerves of a first major Final
on the tour
he's played big tournaments before but
when has he ever played a kind of
two-day match against the world champion
best time ever and okay an exchange of
Pawns and I'm expecting Magnus not to
trade off pieces that consistent kind of
theme over the last few moves is keeping
the tension trying to play for the
maximum maybe this white Bishop on the
edge of the board will come the whole
way back yeah in time Against The Black
Queen on the other side
I I think the same I think he's either
going to do that or he's perhaps going
to swing the queen across to the right
and say well if the trade is happening
it's on my terms yeah White Queen can be
improved
um so Magnus down to four and a half
minutes are we going to see putting some
pressure on the clock okay he does
exchange off slightly surprising to me
but maybe he thought that the black dark
Squad Bishop was his remaining Defender
the black dark School Bishop was a good
defender of his King and now Magnus has
got a huge strategic threat right yeah
we have to get the Bulldog it's a
demolition job
yeah for example if black plays on the
wrong side of the board this queen is
misplaced remember if she tries to for
example improve herself the threat is
along this diagonal and uh White is
threatening to take this Pawn winning a
pawn if the bishop is captured now this
check wins on the spot because the
Knight will fall next the black king is
devoid of any shelter and game over so
Eric guys he did indeed defend against
that threat he brought his Rook forward
one square this is a trick now if you
capture same thing it's a track it looks
deadly but you can meet this with a
block and actually the White Queen is
pinned to her King Whitewood loose so
Magnus instead just side steps it's just
so calm it just all looks so logical in
hindsight magnus's moves but they're not
easy to find at first and the whole idea
is firstly now again this threat is
re-established now that the white king
isn't on that g line but also uh that
talking of that g line the White Rock
it's ready to come and put more pressure
on this Pawn as well
we might just be seeing a big
breakthrough any moment on this Square
yeah
it looks
looks like our journey is just
completely helpless I mean Magnus has
not put a foot wrong apart from that one
tiny moment yeah and what was that tiny
moment the bishop moved yeah it looks
like after that that's that must have
been part of his genius plan it's like
some it's just been Relentless you know
he said well you know look at the black
queen look at the night the offside and
I know exactly what I want to do the
pawn structure tells me to initiate
operations on against the black king
and now he just as David's highlighting
the Knight can step forward into an
outpost and uh by an outpost I mean a
square that cannot be attacked by a pawn
do you think it was part of his genius
plan David yeah I mean
the move we showed earlier with uh if we
just backtrack quickly on the analysis
board the move we saw earlier with white
planting his Bishop on the side of the
board it's very very strong from a human
point of view but we saw the evaluation
bar drop a computer Sports spot that
this Pawn push is actually quite good
for black but it's just not a human move
it's incredibly tough it requires
so much calculation so much judgment and
I don't think we can blame either Magnus
or Arjun for not even considering that I
don't think I would have considered it
unless I saw the evaluation bar which we
did uh so yeah I mean that has led to
the current position uh if we go back to
the current position and uh yeah I'm
expecting Magnus firstly he's
calculating whether he can break through
immediately by sacrificing a bishop the
whole idea would be to try and break
through to the black king
this looks pretty scary for black
Black's King is out in the open but
black can temporarily block with his
Rook maybe with his Knight so it's not
game over yet that's why Magnus is
trying to work this out if he can't
Checkmate immediately by sacrificing on
the Square he will just continue
building up and that has been his
strategy he'll bring his Knight into the
center and yeah he mentioned the word
Outpost to Ivanka this is like the dream
this is like the definition of outpost
it should be in the dictionary because
uh the White Knight is supported by both
its pawns and it can never ever be
challenged by any of Black's Pawns you
can only ever be traded off by the Black
Knight but uh I don't think black can
move his Pieces away from the King this
just looks deadly another a fourth piece
attacking this one Pawn
something's got to give I mean what is
this queen doing on the this side of the
board it's in no man's land it's in
Siberia somewhere just
basically not participating in the game
could he uh obviously Magnus and the
moon but could Arjun just move it
move it back into play somehow I think
you're right Kyle uh Magnus okay he
pushes his truck forward he's just gonna
add pressure by bringing his other rook
in and
surely now at least now on the next
couple of moves black has to bring his
Queen back he has to hope that the queen
can somehow defend along this line
but she's still a pretty bad piece she's
a very bad piece I do feel that Arjun is
just forced to wait and okay I like this
move by Arjun you know move the knight
in front of the king
potentially the Knight can move to more
active posts but uh unlikely in the near
future
I mean look at Magnus he's not even
trying to disguise his intentions he's
lined up his his Bishop his Queen his
two Rooks all against this one pawn and
uh next move I have no doubt Magnus
wants to bring his Bishop his Knight in
for example uh to the square and every
single white piece is hitting this Pawn
at some point there will be a sacrifice
and it's likely to be deadly
so the evaluation bar is still lacking
magnus's position doesn't say it's
winning yet but
it's very good
very difficult for black yeah that's
very very tough position for Arjun and
whilst we're waiting for Argent to find
a defensive move we have some more
questions from our viewers Nicola asks
us will Magnus play the candidates to
try to get back his title in the next
few years
what do we think
it would be funny yeah well if you need
to be the toughest tournament in chess
right the candidates yeah he needs the
challenge
he won it the only time he played in
2013 but he was a bit lucky yeah he's
very lucky to win it in 2013. it would
be cool maybe in like 20 years if Magnus
enters the candidates wins it gets a
match for the title again it's like the
old man come back and says no don't want
to play and then plays again maybe
they're going no no Magnus no more
like Magnus and a bunch of like
teenagers just in the candidates
yeah it would be cool but uh I think
he's not on his radar for now
um not in his plans no
no on his radar now is of course winning
this tournament and uh then to play
hopefully in the next mouthwater
Champions Chester event and then there
is a Fisher random World Championship
coming up
I would say late October yeah I think
October 25th to 30th and he is
definitely playing that in Iceland 50
years after Bobby Fischer became the
world champion in Iceland they are
arranging the fish around the world
championship a uh genre in chess that
Bobby Fischer invented 960 chess so
that's going to be super cool Magnus
will be there Wesley so and then I don't
think we know many other players some
Icelandic yeah Grandmaster yeah um
there's an Icelandic player I think
they're a qualifying events right now
they might even end up being plays like
Nakamura and others who have been trying
to qualify uh playing there it will be
really fun actually and just to watch
but also Magnus that's the one Crown
that's eluded him throughout his career
oh he wants to be world champion and
meanwhile he's broken through he has
broken through he has sacrificed that
peace and now arjun's King is in
dangerous territory will it survive
it looks unlikely yeah I mean it's not
just a I mean I don't really see a
threat right now but it's a long-term
attack yes how are you going to stop
there
teamwork of the White Queen her Rooks
the White Knight coming in you can't you
can't stop anything and I mean if you're
feeling sadistic you can even once
you've introduced all your pieces into
attack you can just Advance the H Pawn
yeah nothing nothing to be done gosh
black can barely move actually black
dress has to sit and await his fate
I mean this has just been
a full strategic game just slow slow
build up blocking things up putting
pieces on good squares and then the
moment comes crash through and yeah I
mean I feel sorry for Arjun I don't
think anyone could have saved this game
after Magnus got the opening or type of
opening he wanted
just been one-way traffic okay Arjun
bringing his Knight in Magnus trying to
trade off those Knights yeah
yeah and uh the white Rook is entering
the battle and this trade was forced
because Magnus had a deadly checkmating
threat uh with the queen on age seven
and uh still Arjun although he's traded
he's still completely tied down he
doesn't have a single active move I mean
all he has to do is just Shuffle his
Queen and rook and yeah hope for the
best and all them while I'm thinking
is he isn't there a deadly threat of
sliding The Rook to the H line yeah
there is you're right Ivanka if uh if
black just loses a move then this is
deadly uh you're pinning everything on
this file and one check is gonna tip the
black defenses over the edge
there's literally no way to stop this if
the black Rook moves for example this is
a check the king is forced to shuffle to
the side you give another check the king
moves and is Checkmate in two uh the
Knight finally drops the king is forced
forward and look at this the three white
pieces are deep in the black Camp have
checkmated the black king and uh how do
you stop this in the current position
the only way I see is ah I'm trying to
Forex but maybe Mike just says I don't
care you just step back one square and
you do the same again you use this
Square this time to break through on the
H file and uh it's the idea of sliding
The Rook across and then this track
and there we go it's on the board Magnus
again last move doesn't exchange pieces
and uh no Trader Brooks White's attack
would suddenly die if you trade pieces
off so he steps back and
this looks winning move the rock across
one square
that looks like game over
it is game over because I think that
Knights these are numbers uh but uh okay
well Magnus being flashy he is being
flashy he don't care he's not gonna go
straight for the kill he's gonna grab as
much material as possible enjoy the
journey they say yeah and he took a Pawn
on the Square the Knight cannot take the
White Queen because the Knight is pinned
uh Black's Knight is pinned to its king
it's uh it's illegal unfortunately to
come capture that white queen and a big
threat on the board of actually playing
Rook takes Knight I think this is a
killer actually yeah and uh there we go
I think Eric icy has resigned facing a
deadly attack from the world number one
wow what a start to the final Magnus
Carlsen he wins a dominant game here
with the white pieces in his hunt to
reach 2 900 on